wer hat was in der FDP nach diesem war
ja eine Art friedensschwur da in
Meseberg eigentlich nicht
kapiert jetzt müssen Sie mir sagen was
sie genau meinen also Kanzler sagte da
wird jetzt in Zukunft gehämert und so
weiter aber mit schalämpfer wir sind aus
der Sommerpause zurückgekehrt und ich
hätte mir eine erste Kabinettsitzung
gewünscht wo die großen Dinge gleich
entschieden werden und dann hat die
Bundesfamilienministerin gesagt beim
Wachstum chancengesetz also der Sommer
war ja geprägt von der Frage der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres Landes der
Bundesfinanzminister hat ein gutes
Gesetz vorgelegt das hat sie dann
angehalten im Schloss Meseberg die
Bilder sehen wir gerade im Hintergrund
ist das aufgelöst worden ich halte es an
der Stelle tatsächlich mit Robert
habbeck das war kein Glanzstück hätte
nicht sein müssen aber jetzt ist das
Gesetz beschlossen und noch
bürokratische Entlastung beschlossen
worden und die Richtung stimmt so da
sagt auch Herr südikum das ist
grundsätzlich eine gute Sache aber mich
interessiert diese AKB Diskussion diese
kernkraftdiskussion die da jetzt
plötzlich wieder kommt warum also meine
meine Fraktion kann ich ihn ganz genau
sagen hat in der letzten Woche wie viele
Fraktionen im Bundestag eine
Klausurtagung gehabt umfangreiches
Papier 15 Seiten glaube ich ein Punkt
war da drin den ich übrigens glaube ich
sogar in dieser Sendung schon vor
einigen Monaten gesagt habe und die
Frage gestellt habe ist es klug in einer
angespannten Situation wo die
Strompreise steigen äh jetzt mit dem
Rückbau der Kernkraftwerke die noch
funktionieren frühzeitig zu beginnen
oder sollten wir die Option offen halten
zumindestens und schauen wie wir die
Stromversorgung in Zukunft in
Deutschland gewährleisten die Frage habe
ich gestellt die stelle ich auch
weiterhin unter anderem habe ich es in
dieser Sendung glaube ich sogar vor
einigen Monaten formuliert da ist es
dann nicht so laut geworden manchmal ist
der mediale Resonanzraum unterschiedlich
aber entscheidener Herr LZ entscheiden
Herr LZ wie ich das kurz ausführen darf
sind weitere Punkte wir haben gerade die
Frage schon im antext da gehabt
industriestrompreis wo wir nein sagen
und stattessen alles gleich ich will
sagen kein Papier genau es ist kein
Papier wo wir sagen es geht jetzt um die
Kernenergie und die Kraftwerke sozusagen
der Vergangenheit sondern es geht ganz
konkret darum beim Strompreis was zu tun
der ist zu hoch und deswegen sage ich
lieber Senkung der Stromsteuer okay
reden wir gleich drüber noch mal die
Frage also wie wie soll das Laufen was
haben sie davor mit den AKW die letzten
drei die sollen nicht zurückgebaut
werden also der Rückbau dauert wir
wissen von den anderen Kraftwerken ich
habe ja in Niedersachsen als eines der
Länder die ja viel mit kernenergi in den
letzten Jahren zu tun gehabt hat
entlagung auf der einen Seite Produktion
auf der anderen Seite da fachlich viel
mit zu tun gehabt so ein Rückbau dauert
Jahrzehnte und ich sage achtung wir sind
ein er schwierigen angespannten
Situation das sinden wir am hohen
Strompreis in Deutschland lasass uns
nicht alle Konzentration auf den Rückbau
setzen sondern lass uns überlegen wie
wir weitermachen an der Stelle
insbesondere und das will ich hinzufügen
insbesondere bei der Frage was wir noch
tun können Stichwort Kernfusion in den
USA wird Ende dieses jahrzehns der erste
Stromliefervertrag Gültigkeit haben und
es wird geliefert in dem Bereich
Deutschland kann dem doch nachziehen und
sagen wir machen eigenes Gesetz dafür um
Kernfusion nach vorne zu wirenüber
kernpaltung mehr deswegen sage ich wir
brauchen mehr Kapazität mehr Optionen
und an der Stelle sage ich die eine
Option die noch da wäre nicht als erstes
darum zu kümmern sie zur Seite zu
schieben sondern sie zumindestens auf
dem Tisch sie wollen den rückbauch
stoppen ja für die Kraftwerke die noch
funktionsfähig wären und wieder
anlaufbar wären ja wir reden gleich
darüber ob das sinnvoll ist oder nicht
ich bin ja da auch ganz Technologie
offen ich will es nur verstehen aber
warum zi Tage dre Tage nach
Meseberg man ist froh dass gerade dieser
ganz grundsätzliche Streit beendet ist
und es geht genauso in einer Tour weiter
nein Herr LZ das was ich das was ich
dort gesagt habe z war in Dresden als
ich es gesagt habe und es ist ein
Beschluss meiner Fraktion ist das ein
Punkt den wir seit vielen Monaten
wiederholen und es ist deshalb nicht neu
die neue Botschaft ich komme jetzt mal
weil es geht wirklich um das Thema Strom
zurzeit alle reden davon dass der
Strompreis zu hoch ist die neue
Botschaft war dass wir gesagt haben der
industriestrompreis von vielen
diskutiert im Sommer ist der falsche Weg
der richtig ist eine Senkung der
Stromsteuer das was sie gerade zitieren
ist ein beitenpkt den ich von schon vor
vielen Monaten und aus meiner Erinnerung
sogar an dieser Stelle hier gesagt habe
okay aber sie machen die Atomdiskussion
jetzt noch mal richtig auf und zwar so
sehr dass der Kanzler sagt es ist ein
totes Pferd also bei
to genau man muss ja sich überlegen W
man absteigt muss man sich überlegen
geht man zu Fuß weiter oder sucht man
zumindestens neue Pferde und da bin ich
sehr dafür breiter und weiter zu denken
wir werden Wind und Sonne zubauen aber
es wird nicht ausreichen um den
Strompreis zu stabilisieren im Gegenteil
wir müssen überlegen wie wir
grundlassfähigen Strom in Deutschland
sicherstellen das tun wir zur Zeit mit
der Kohleenergie aber das kann ja nicht
die Option sein bevor ich gleich Frau
Weidenfeld Frage hat das auch was mit
diesen näherrückenden Landtagswahlen in
Hessen und den Bayern zu tun frag nur
das hätten sie mich ja im Prinzip auch
füror 5 Monaten als ich das schon mal
sagte Fragen können aber das jetzt noch
mal so vement aufmachen es es sind zwei
Sätze in einem 15 seitenpapier ich finde
es gut dass rausgegriffen worden ist
weil ich für ein relevanten Punkt haltet
ich will das will das gar nicht beiseite
schieben aber noch mal scheint mediale
Resonanz zu finden insgesamt brauchen
wir eine Energiepolitik die auf eine
Industriegesellschaft und die
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
ausgerichtet ist und da übrigens um den
Schwenker wenn ich das machen darf
verlland zur ia in München gerade zu
machen diskutiert diese
Bundesregierung konkret der
Verkehrsminister in München über
synthetische Kraftstoffe auch das wird
zu Energiepolitik reden wir auch gleich
drüber noch mal sie schlagen das vor sie
wissen ganz genau das ist mit den Grünen
und mit der SPD nicht zu machen sie
wissen also auch das GI wieder richtig
Krach also das warum nein Herr landz ich
glaube da reiten sie gerade ein
merkwürdiges Pferd es geht jetzt um die
konkrete fre soll ganz konkret haben um
die konkrete Frage wollen wir beim
Rückbau schneller werden oder wollen wir
uns ein bisschen wollen wir wollen wir
uns zurückhalten und sagen dass ist
nicht das vordring gerade für die
Kernkraftwerke die noch funktionieren
könnten kann man ihn jetzt anhalten es
dauert ohehin Jahrzehnte den Vorgang
über den wir reden deswegen würde es
jetzt auch nicht so groß machen noch mal
fragen damit ich verstehe wenn es nach
ihnen ginge wenn in dieser
industriestrompreis überhaupt der
Strompreis so wichtig ist würden sie
auch noch weitere AKW im Betrieb nehmen
die ja auch teilweise gerade im Rückbau
sind oder neue sogar dazuauen was ist
die Idee also die Kernkraftwerken der
alten Generation werden nicht mehr
gebaut auch mutmaßig in Europa in
Zukunft nicht mehr es geht schon um die
Frage das machen die Amerikaner die
Generator die Kernkraftwerke der neuen
Generation darüber nachzudenken da
werden wir als FDP offen übrigens auch
das ist kein Geheimnis das hat glaube
ich die FDP im April auf ihrem letzten
bundesparte also alles kein Geheimnis
wir haben da energiepolitische
Vorstellung die sind teilweise nicht
deckungsgleich mit denen sowohl übrigens
nicht der SPD und der grün teilweise
sogar der Union die Union hat
daungsverantwortung auch anders gesehen
da geht's aber nicht ich Beton es noch
mal weil wir technisch da genau sein
müssen um die alten
kernpaltrededaktoren der Vergangenheit
sondern kleinere Reaktoren der Zukunft
die in anderen Teilen der Welt gebaut
werden auch darüber muss man nachdenken
ich finde Deutschland war super darin zu
sagen wo wir aussteigen wir müssen auch
sagen wo wir einsteigen Frau Weidenfeld
ja bei dem letzten Satz wä ich sofort
dabei aber sie wollen ja gar nicht
wieder einsteigen sie sagen ja nur wir
wollen die als Reserve halten und das
macht eben mit dem Strompreis erstmal
gar nichts und das zweite was eben
komisch ist ist sie haben ja dem
Ausstieg zugestimmt es hat ja einen
koalitionsk Kompromiss gegeben als als
die Verlängerung bis April beschlossen
wurde da kann ich mich erinnern sind FDP
Spitzenpolitiker Arm in Arm mit dem
Kanzler durch Berlin gezogen und haben
erklärt wir sind ja eigentlich eine
sozialliberale Koalition und die Grünen
sind eben wie auch dabei und das ist so
ein bisschen das irritierende dass sie
das jetzt wieder auspacken was sie
gemeinschaftlich eingepackt haben im
letzten Winter ob das klug war oder
nicht ich würde eben auch tendenziell
eher sagen es war nicht klug das zu
machen aber sie haben es gemacht sie
haben es mitgemacht und jetzt sieht man
dass die FDP in Hessen und in Bayern
sagen wir mal so innerhalb der
schätzungsunsicherheiten bei der 5%
Marke ist und jetzt auf einmal ist es
wieder da ein Thema was sie
find schon also ich finde die die
Debatte nicht nicht illegitim ich finde
sie auch nicht unanständig aber dass sie
jetzt wieder da ist und dass sie eben
kurz nach Meseberg da ist und dass sie
da ist nachdem es im im letzten Winter
dieselbe Diskussion schon mal gegeben
hat wo die FDP als Siegerin vom Hof
gegangen ist da hat man schon den
Eindruck dass es natürlich was mit
Hessen und Bayern zu tun hat und mit
einer AFD Partei die sagt wir steigen
morgen wieder ein ich will zunächst mal
den Punkt anknüpfen was den
kernenergieustieg in deland betrifft und
will nur einfach mal ganz kurz Z
bayerischen Umweltminister den man heute
auch noch kennt der in Amt und Würden
ist zitieren der gesagt hat wenn zum
31.12 in Deutschland die Kernkraftwerke
nicht abgeschaltet sind und Bayern dann
trete ich zurück genau auf den Rücktritt
von der Söder warte ich bis heute ich
will damit nur eins sagen diese
Entscheidung hat insbesondere eine
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung
vorangetrieben und wir haben sie
vorgefunden und haben dann gesagt in ein
ganz schwierigen Phase Oktober 2022 wir
gehen in die Verlängerung also das
Atomgesetz ist mit nicht ich sag's nur
Frau weidenf WE weiß das auch der
firnesshalber mit nichten durch die FDP
entschieden worden sondern es war
entschieden ich sage falsch entschieden
ich habe da nur keine Mehrheit für im
Deutschen Bundestag und wir sind dann
tatsächlich in die Verlängerung gegangen
und jetzt ganz kurz zu der Frage des
Rückbaus noch mal Herr landz jetzt
stelle ich mir eine Sekunde vor ich
würde in gleicher Sendung sitzen in dem
Papier h es nicht gestanden da würde der
Moderator Land zurecht Fragen also her
dur vor vier Monaten haben Sie davon
gesprochen dass man beim rückw jetzt mal
die Bremse ziehen muss und jetzt
erwähnen sie das nicht mehr was kann den
da mit der FDP sein sie nälich gesagt
ich
gesagt
mon mon was ich vor vier Monaten als FDP
Politiker für richtig gehalten habe das
sage ich auch vier Monate später
vollkommen egal welche
landtagswahltermine stattfinden ich
finde das gehört einfach zu Seriosität
dazu dass man seine Meinung hat so wie
die SPD sagt beispielsweise bin ich
vielleicht wie Herr südekum eine
Schuldenbremse finden wir nicht so gut
da sagen wir als FDP wir finden eine
Schuldenbremse richtig aber ich will ja
der SPD jetzt des lieben Friedenswillen
Herr lands nicht verbieten ihre Haltung
zur Schulden Bremse darzustellen die der
Haltung der FDP ist eine andere und wir
halten sie auch in der Bundesregierung
durch sie haben gerade das Wort seriös
benutzt und das ist für sie der Nachweis
für seriöität WE ist es wirklich seriös
wenn man die eigene Regierung auch den
eigenen Kanzler letztenendes ist ja die
Regierung der sie angehören nicht Sie
persönlich aber viele ihrer Minister
wenn man die so am Nasenring durch die
Arena zieht das ist ja nicht der Fall
die Frage ist doch sollte ein Politiker
sein Tage danach zwei Tage nachdem der
kan die Frage ist doch vielleicht für
den Soziologen interessant sollte ein
Politiker der vor vier Monaten etwas
gesagt hat er für richtig gehalten hat
wenn er vier Monate danach noch der
gleiche Meinung ist sollte er die
Meinung wiederholen oder sollte sie aus
taktischen Gründen verschweigen ich
finde der muss ehrlich seine Meinung
sagen ich habe niemandung kostet Sie
nichts Herr das klingt jetzt so henhaft
diese Meinung kostet Sie nichts wenn Sie
wenn Sie wirklich diese Haltung hätten
dann müsen sie doch darauf hinarbeiten
und sagen okay das ist unsere tiefe
Überzeugung dann gehen wir raus aus
dieser Koalition dann nehme ich sie
ernst nein ja aber das ist ja gerade zu
lustig wenn sie sagen wenn ich mich
nicht zu 100% durchsetze dann mache ich
keine Koalition natürlich heißt eine
genau eine Koalition heißt Kompromiss
aber aber es ist nichts falsch daran
finde ich und das passt vielleicht zu
dem anfangszitat was sie beim antext da
sagten dass ich finde Parlamentarismus
heißt auch in der Sache nicht im
persönlichen in der Sache
Auseinandersetzung dass Parteien
unterschiedliche Haltung
haben bevor wir dann gleich beantworten
wo die wo die Wähler geblieben sind was
sagt der topökonom in der Runde Herr
südikum jetzt mal ganz offen
argumentativ offen nicht nur Technologie
offen ja diskutiert würde es was bringen
diese diese Meiler weiter laufen zu
lassen oder anders gefragt mit Blick auf
das riesige Thema Strom und es geht ja
nicht nur um Industrie sondern jeder in
diesem Land stöhnt unter viel zu hohen
Strompreisen und das ist übrigens nicht
er seit dem ukrainekrieg so würde es was
bringen diese Meiler weiterlaufen zu
lassen also ich habe kein
grundsätzliches Problem mit
Kernenergie und ich glaube aber jetzt in
der konkreten Krisensituation wo wir ja
waren hat's mir auch sage ich mal nicht
eingeleuchtet dass man ausgerechnet dann
die Atomkraftwerke abschalteet das
verstehe ich alles die Argumentation
aber wenn man auf die Fakten schaut ist
es doch so zum Ausstiegszeitpunkt reden
wir noch über 6% der Stromerzeugung die
zu dem Zeitpunkt noch aus Atom kam mhm
hätte man sich jetzt entschieden sie
weiterlaufen zu lassen hätte man neue
Brennstäbe bestellen müssen es hätte
ewig gedauert das heißt sie wärden
sofort gar nicht einsatzfähig gewesen
hätte sich dann nicht ein Z Jahre an die
Atomkraft gebunden um sozusagen die
Krise zu überstehen sondern hätte sie
dann wieder 10 Jahre wahrscheinlich an
der Backe gehabt mit den neuen
brennstehben und das leäuchtet mir
irgendwie nicht ein ich verstehe auch
jetzt wirklich nicht warum diese
Diskussion jetzt so geführt wird die
Regierung und auch die FDP hat es ja
geschafft wirklich aus der Krise
wirklich sehr gut rauszufinden weil
jetzt sehen wir ja der Ausbau der
neuebahn hat jetzt endlich richtig Tempo
aufgenommen onshore Wind offshore wind
solar die Ausbauziele sind jetzt bei
weiten übertroffen was noch nicht gesagt
wurde was aber ganz wichtig ist der
prüsselstein ist Gas ja also wir haben
ja die LNG terminals in Windeseile quasi
genehmigt errichtet und darüber wird die
Kapazitäten die da geschaffen werden
werden die russladlücke beim Gas nicht
nur schließen sondern stark
überkompensieren und auch das ist
sozusagen der Baustein der dann eben für
die Verstromung genutzt werden kann das
heißt sozusagen das Stromsystem der
Zukunft ist erneuerbar mit Gas als
Backup und deswegen werden die
Strompreise auch wieder perspektivisch
sinken da bin ich ziemlich fest von
überzeugt und deswegen glaube ich auch
dass dieser brückenstrompreis richtig
ist ih heute einzuführen und für diese
ganze Diskussion braucht man die
Atomkraft nicht und deswegen verstehe
ich nicht warum man für diesen einen
Aspekt der noch für 6% verantwortlich
war warum man sozusagen den ganzen Tag
über dieses Thema diskutiert und nicht
auch als FDP sagt wir hatten unseren
Anteil daran dass wir aus der Krise
wirklich gut herausgefunden haben da
noch mal ganz kurz ein paar Zahlen dazu
in die Runde ist sehr interessant ich
vor einiger Zeit mit jemandem mal
intensiver darüber ausgetauscht der
sagte die Erneuerbaren liefern heute
doppelt so viel Strom wie die AKW in
ihrer besten Zeit das ist eine Menge
Frau Weidenfeld bestätigt das in Wind
und Sonnenenergie wurden in den letzten
20 Jahren in Deutschland im Schnitt 15
Milliarden Euro jährlich investiert
privates Geld das heißt da ist ein Markt
entstanden da ist irgendetwas passiert
noch interessanter wird's wenn man sich
das mal weltweit anschaut hab eine Zahl
für 2021 die ist beeindruckend da gingen
weltweit 250 Gigawatt erneuerbare ans
Netz und 0,4 Gigawatt Atom
250 versus 0,4 das heißt Atomkraft
liefert unter 5% des globalen
Energiebedarfs teilweise hab global
leider leider
nochr eine Sache nocher zwei Sachen noch
die Kosten es gab ein Atomkraftwerk das
in Finland ans Netz gegangen ist z
Jahresbeginn dreimal so viermal so teuer
wie geplant statt 3 Milliarden 12
Milliarden und wenn man sich mal
anschaut auch Frankreich das ja gerne
beschrieben wird als ein Land in dem
sozusagen Atomkraft das Ding überhaupt
ist interessanterweise haben die so viel
Bedarf alte morsche Atom Kraftwerke
abzuschalten und neue zu bauen dass sie
per saldo in Wahrheit nicht in Atomkraft
einsteigen sondern aussteigen ist hoch
subventioniert ist unvorstellbar teuer
und eigentlich funktioniert es nicht und
jetzt habe ich über die Frage der
brennelementelagerung noch gar nicht
gesprochen jetzt müssen sie mich nicht
davon überzeugen dass die alten
Generationen nicht neu gebaut werden
sollten also das finnische Beispiel was
sie w wäre es nicht wäre nicht
sinnvoller zu sagen pass auf wir sind
doch diese eine Regierung wir wollten
progressiv sein wir uns jetzt ein
Schalldämpfer verordnet wollen wir nicht
gemeinsam endlich mal auch strukturell
die Zukunft dieses Landes wirklich
gestalten statt jetzt so ein altes Ding
wieder aus der Mottenkiste zu holen Herr
L ich bin Herr südikum sehr dankbar dass
er das Thema LNG deutlich gemacht hat
unterstrichen hat welche Erfolge wir da
hatten ichä mich in meiner Zeit als
niedersächsischer Landespolitiker da
habe ich gesagt Leute wir brauchen diese
LG Terminals viele Jahre her da wurde
gesagt Herr dür Jahrzehnte dauert das
jetzt haben wir gezeichnet
Regierungsverantwortung das dauert vier
Monate und man schafft das tatsächlich
also vollkommen richtig ichich allerings
auch Herr Lanz wenn ich das sagen darf
als ich das hier einmal vortrug haben
sie so s gemäß gesagt ja ja ist ja gut
das wissen wir ja allesof finde ich toll
dass südkum das noch mal unterstreicht
welche Erfolge wir da regverwortungen
häufig darüber deswegen muss man das
nicht jedes Mal als
Werb warum reden sie nicht mehr darüber
ich bin froh dass wir jetzt mal drüber
reden können
richtig jetzt ja
aber der Sache richtig D Erfolg wichtig
ist jetzt eins zu unterscheiden das
betrifft beispielsweise Gas auch über
die sythetischen Kra Stoffe die wir
reden auch über grundlassfähige andere
Stromproduzenten ist ein Unterschied zu
dem was wir an Herausforderung bei den
erneuerbahn haben die nicht stetig
produzieren deswegen kann man nicht ganz
die installierte Leistung nicht ganz
Frau weidfeld ich darf kurz ausführen
nicht ganz die installierte Leistung
einfach eins zu eins vergleichen der
Vergleich wäre zu einfach zu sagen so
und so viel Fotovoltaik hab wir so und
so viel Kernenergie hatten wir oder
haben wir jetzt ein Braunkohle werden
wir an Gaskraftwerken stetig haben das
funktioniert nicht ganz sondern das
System ändert sich an der stelle ich bin
freue mich über den Zubau bei den
Erneuerbaren aber ich will einen Hinweis
geben und deswegen ist der Import von
Energie für die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft und exportnu in
Deutschland nach wie vor wichtig wir
brauchen auch stetige Energieträger die
verlässlich erzeugen und das genau
grundlastfähigkeit und da wird muss man
über den Stromsektor hinausdenken da
wird der Verkehrssektor eine große Rolle
spielen ich wollte nur sagen dass
die gerade bei der grundlastfähigkeit
hätte würde ich mir immer wünschen dass
die Energie der Bundesregierung
natürlich auch der FDP viel viel stärker
eben gehen würde in den Ausbau der Netze
weil wir wissen ja dass die Erneuerbaren
inzwischen fast grundlastfähig sind oder
schon grundlastfähig wären wenn wir den
Strom der sozusagen in Irland beim
ersten Wind entsteht dann eben auch
schön transferieren könnten innerhalb
Europas von Nord nach Süd von West nach
Ost und das können wir aber nicht weil
wir eben die Netze dafür nicht haben und
weil die Bundesregierung das
deutschlandtempo zwar für LNG Terminals
angewendet hat aber eben für den
höchstleistungsnetz Ausbau nicht und das
ist glaube ich ein echtes Problem wie
übrigens auch Herr südekum ist ein
echtes Problem ist dass auch die
windkraftinstallationen so teuer
geworden sind dass jedenfalls onshore in
diesem in diesem Jahr im Wind nicht viel
passiert in Deutchland